un petit voyage tout de suite dans les
balkans en force comme on dit en
première grâce à vous antoine et anaïs
vous avez développé un projet qui est
assez particulier ça s'appelle
initiative balkans convergence balkans
de quoi s'agit-il
antoine c'est un projet qui est porté
par anaïs et par plusieurs partenaires
c'est un projet initié par erasmus plus
et l'association dijonnaise magna boxe
et le but c'était faire converger une
trentaine de jeunes dans trois villes
différentes
skopje en macédoine jouent en français
patras en grèce et les faire réfléchir
et travailler sur plusieurs
problématiques les problématiques
migratoires et problématiques
écologiques et les problématiques de
culture par exemple bon mais presque
tout deal à trois équipes
trois spécialistes je me tourne vers
vous qui êtes un peu l'intendante
finalement de cette opération
convergence balkans pourquoi vous l'avez
monte alors c'était dans l'idée de
rassembler déjà des jeunes autour de la
question européenne donc qu'à évoquer
antoine juste avant et les faire
réfléchir tous ensemble et de trouver
surtout des initiatives positives dans
chaque pays des associations des
personnes qui oeuvrent pour l'écologie
pour l'aide aux réfugiés et autour de la
culture générale la musique la cuisine
voilà qu'est ce que ça vous a apporté à
tous les deux je commencerai que toi
maïs alors pas déjà d'échanger avec des
personnes qui sont à l'étranger qui
n'ont pas les mêmes façons de
fonctionner ça nous a appris beaucoup de
choses on s'est vite rendu compte avec
notre première semaine et skopje
des différences qui pouvait y avoir dans
les pratiques culturelles dans la façon
de gérer aussi les réfugiés est aussi en
écologie on n'a pas forcément les mêmes
initiatives et donc du coup c'est vrai
que d'abord de l'apprentissage pour moi
qu'est ce qui t'a le plus plu dans ces
rencontres différentes à travers ses
expériences
alors peut-être la rencontre de tout le
monde autour de la cuisine et de la
musique ce que c'est vrai que c'est les
deux thématiques qui ont permis de
rassembler tout le monde on avait des
groupes de musique dans chaque pays des
cuisines et dans chaque pays donc il ya
eu un vrai plaisir à partager sur ces
deux thématiques là donc c'est ce qui
m'a aussi le plus plus amusé t'as pas vu
de sculpture sur fruits et légumes non
voilà pourquoi c'est unique et on va à
sculpter
carottes d'ici la fin de cette émission
mais d'abord je me tourne vers vous
antoine c'est vrai on le disait il ya
plusieurs thématiques écologie à venir
de l'union européenne
problème migratoire culture censure sans
faire de politique
vraiment vous êtes intéressé à des
choses très terre à terre très pratique
qui concerne vraiment tous les jeunes
mais je pense que à cinq jours des
élections européennes on a besoin de se
poser ces questions-là et le fait que ce
soit une trentaine de jeunes qui se pose
ces questions qui travaillent sur ces
problématiques
je pense que c'est important de les
mettre en avant et c'est ce que nous a
france 3 bourgogne on a voulu faire en
suivant le projet d'ici de nos bureaux à
dijon et voilà mais vous êtes parti de
skopje en macédoine pour nous expliquer
un petit peu vous n'êtes pas une carte
quelque chose pour vous montrer la cg on
voit un peu qu'on essaie de se
visualiser tout ça parce que je suis sûr
vous savez denis où ça se trouve skopje
en macédoine fin maintenant vous avez la
carte soleil tant que c'est beaucoup
plus facile
c'est beaucoup plus facile mais c'est
vrai que on sait pas forcément
expliquez-nous antoine ils sont partis
dijon le lundi 6 mai ils ont pris le bus
jusqu'à la fin je parle sous le contrôle
d'anaïs mais jusqu'à mulhouse il ya
mulhouse un avion jusqu à skopje
ils sont restés une semaine ils sont
revenus le 14 mais voilà ils sont restés
une semaine à dijon et ils repartent fin
août en grèce à patras et patras et
skopje ces deux villes ont été choisies
parce qu'en fait ces deux villes deux
grandes villes portuaires avec enfin
surtout pas trace avec des
problématiques migratoires très
importante et parce que pas tracer un
peu calé finalement un petit peu ouais
et skopje aussi faim je pense cannabis
pourrait me le dire que moi mais c'est
surtout un lieu de passage pour les
réfugiés skopje en tout cas pas tracée
dans le lieu d'arrivée en macédoine
finalement il y en a assez peu des
réfugiés
mais c'est surtout un lieu de passage
sinon qu'est ce que vous avez fait de
toute cette expérience vous l'avez
stockés dans vos cerveaux ça j'ai bien
compris il ya plein d'imagés ça
scintille dans les yeux d'anaïs
le voit de très près ici mais pour ceux
qui sont avec nous et qui se disent
d'accord très gentil très jolie cette
opération convergence marquant mais moi
je suis au fin fond de la bourgogne
franche comté je me dis que ce que je
fais quoi alors c'est vrai qu'en direct
quand on était en voyage c'est antoine
qui a recueilli tous nos témoignages on
lui a fait des petites vidéos au jour le
jour et après on a aussi du contenu
journalistique qui va sortir
prochainement
ce qu'on a énormément de deux matières
donc delà du contenu vidéo du contenu
écrit qu'ils vont sortir prochainement
sur nos réseaux et notre site internet
de quelques photos je crois antoine que
vous pouvez montrer en même temps et
même une petite vidéo que j'ai carrément
une petite vidéo ou alors on va mettre
le son assez pas nécessaire non regarder
que les images c'est un carnet de voyage
voilà le but c'était justement suivre
nous de dijon le voyage à ce que
j'espère qu'on le voit pas ce que nous
on voit la wii et on fera la même chose
quand l'équipe partira en grèce et anaïs
le disais je
il m'envoyait des vidéos et des photos
régulièrement et moi je monte des
petites vis des petites vidéos dans ce
dans ce style là pour raconter un petit
peu tout leur épopée
et puis il y avait des articles aussi
qui racontait toutes leurs aventures à
skopje en macédoine
si je vous dis on est tous européens
mais nos cultures sont tellement
différentes
anaïs c'est exactement ça c'est ce qu'on
sait ce dont on s'est rendu compte quand
on est parti à skopje même s'ils font
pas encore partie l'union européenne
c'est une volonté de la part de ce pays
d'en faire partie mais on a aussi
remarqué c'est différent cela avec avec
les grecs on a rencontré sur place on
voit vous étiez combien là alors là
c'est uniquement l'équipe française on
était vingt-et-une personnes et après il
y avait douze personnes chez les
macédoniens et 12 personnes chez les
grecs aussi finalement c'est un carnet
de voyage pour vivre l'aventuré comme si
on y était ce soir tout à fait c'est
vraiment l'idée c'est de partager ce
qu'on a fait quand on était là-bas et
que les gens puissent prendre conscience
en même temps que nous des initiatives
qu'on a pu qu'on a pu découvrir avec des
contenus radio des vidéos des photos
développe comme on dit les vidéos c'est
pas les blogs c'est encore autre chose
les articles des photos fait du
journalisme de maintenant qu antoine
c'est tout à fait ça et le blog c'était
une idée qu'on a réfléchi ensemble
puisque c'était on vous les nouvelles
écritures et raconte l aventure
autrement et
les analyses c'est qu'un millier de
coordinatrice du projet se filmer et me
raconter leur journée
moi ça me permettait de savoir ce
qu'elle faisait sur place et de pouvoir
l'exploiter ensuite sur le site ça
s'appelle convergence balkans rendez
vous sur notre site web platform de
france télévisions instagram youtube
aussi pour partager cette expérience
inédite vous restez avec nous jusqu'à la
fin de cette émission vous savez pas ce
culte et des carottes vous pas du tout